hello hello hello thank you so much
everyone for coming to the show everyone
looks so good if you're like is she
staring at me the answer is yes
um we have a really big show for you
today a whole lot of show we're
celebrating the super bowl
and
we are talking football cramming snacks
and yes pet and puppies
and then we have a rom-com love fest
with an all-star cast from the new film
i want you back and then we're talking
about love gone wrong with the women
from the shocking new documentary the
tinder swindler they're here
i know
and uh we're gonna hear their story this
is the one everybody's been talking
about they're gonna give us all the
details and maybe things that you can't
get from the documentary so i'm very
excited about this but first i like to
hit the headlines i like to find out
what's happening in the world so let's
get some good news
[Applause]
[Applause]
all right it's time for drew's news your
tasty news weenies wrapped in good news
blankets
and with me at the desk is the
co-captain of our news team rusty russ
matthews hey everybody
hi
hi rossi yeah you're a big football fan
no i am so i grew up watching football
it was like the only way i could
communicate with my brother and dad was
like watching seahawk games and now it's
like this lifelong love affair i am so
ready for the big game this sunday are
you guys going to watch
i cannot wait because it's all about
just
gathering around with people everybody's
watching it it's like a
shared experience we're all doing
together that being said let's turn to
some people who are really the
aficionados and authorities two
incredible sports geniuses hosts of the
podcast naked with carrie champion
please welcome carrie champion hi carrie
and contributing writer for the atlantic
and host of jemele hill is unbothered
the one and only jemele hill hello
hi all right now this is a historic
super bowl it's the first ever in sofie
stadium in englewood california and only
the second time in nfl history that a
team gets to play on their home turf so
tell us do the rams have the advantage
here well i i'm gonna say i'm from l.a
so i am rams die hard anything la i'm
going with ramps but if i'm honest if
i'm just being honest with both of you
guys and ross you know this the bengals
have something special and dare i say
that i'm leaning towards in my like in
my mind i think they may win but i'm
rooting for the rams holy right i'm
hedging my bets right now jamal
thoughts feelings all of it
okay well first of all let me just warn
you guys i'm petty okay and so
as you see behind me this is the san
francisco 49er helmet because i am a
49ers fan so i hate the rams because
they're in our division we lost to them
in the nfc championship i was there to
witness this in person so
because i value my soul i'm not rooting
for the rant
the bagels to me
i love that
yes
that's football to me
you got to be brutal right now that's
the kind of moxie i want that's the kind
of moxie i relate to
um but i think i'm like feeling the
bangles i'm just gonna say it
and i love los angeles i'm going to be
in so much trouble and i will be so
happy if they win uh but welcome back to
la and being the second team in history
last year tampa with the bucks
now
at you know rams and sofi there's just
so much good stuff to talk about and
it's why i'm picking the rams by the way
to win i just have to say i'm okay
so oh this you'll make a friendly bet
yes i will okay i will eat okay what
about this
drew if if your prediction comes true
that the bengals win i will eat a whole
bowl of macaroni and cheese
okay which she tries to force feed me on
the regular no idea how that how big
that is for him and if the rams win my
prediction comes right you have to watch
an entire episode of 90 day fiance all
right
guys wait but neither neither one of
these sound like punishment i don't know
and
jesus
is 90 day fiance
right now i might have to eat macaroni
and cheese while i watch beyonce and
same thing
[Music]
you